nature et tranquillité sont les grands
attraits de vivre en campagne c'est du
moins ce qui a convaincu James Jackson
de s'installer à marinade vous êtes
capable de prendre votre café tranquille
dehors exactement beaucoup
mais ça qui est apprécié ces petits à
petit effrités en raison du bruit
routier
et à monter régulièrement depuis des
années particulièrement des
motocyclistes mais aussi des voitures et
des grosses camions de temps en temps
si fort que Jane a certains moments
était contraint de rentrer à l'intérieur
le bruit était aussi haut qu'on peut pas
parler c'est à 7 niveaux là c'est que la
municipalité est traversée par deux
routes provinciales avec des limites de
vitesse allant jusqu'à 90 km/h
il circule gros camion voiture bruyante
et motocyclette en été
puis la population est passée de 2100 à
4900 résidents permanents en 20 ans
faisant augmenter la circulation tout
comme les plaintes à propos de la
pollution sonore le maire et son équipe
ont décidé de prendre les choses en main
a décidé d'y aller avec une campagne de
sensibilisation
l'installation de sonomètre et en
partenariat avec la santé du Québec de
faire des opérations antibruit donc il
venait il donnait des contrevations ou
récalstrait la municipalité est parmi
les premières au Québec à se doter de
sonomètre
ce sont des appareils qui ressemblent à
des afficheurs de vitesse mais qui
calcule les décibels ils sont
régulièrement utilisés en Europe et
c'est l'équipe de Martin Robert qui a
adapté le produit pour la municipalité
contrairement ici en Europe à Paris ils
ont développé des produits à la demande
aussi du gouvernement ils ont développé
des produits qui permettent de calculer
les niveaux de bruit les micros sont
installés en amont du panneau indicateur
puis les messages diffusés dédiés à
sensibiliser les citoyens peuvent varier
notre première installation l'image
qu'on voit c'est l'oreille trop bruyant
puis il y a différents messages qu'on
peut mettre tout va dépendre à ce
moment-là du niveau d'intensité du bruit
selon les Nations unies la pollution
sonore est un danger croissant pour la
santé humaine mais aussi pour la
biodiversité
ça va être surtout chez les animaux qui
utilisent une communication acoustique
comme par exemple les oiseaux ou les
amphibiens ben ça va évidemment
dégrader la communication entre les
individus c'est certain que n'importe
quel réglementation qu'on m'a en place
pour atténuer le dérangement sur
nous-mêmes ça a des mêmes effets
positifs sur la forme le ronronnement
des moteurs se fait toujours entendre
chez James Jackson mais beaucoup moins
fort qu'avant la municipalité elle
continuera la sensibilisation pour
préserver sa sérénité je suis très
content que au minimum ça diminue ici
Elisa serrer Radio-Canada